what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and new reports tell us that we have our
Mr Fantastic of the Fantastic Four for
the upcoming Fantastic Four Marvel
Cinematic Universe reboot according to
reports from some insiders Adam Driver
is going to be Mr Fantastic in the
Fantastic Four movie if the deal that
they're working on right now gets
finalized right now they're in
negotiations and talks with Marvel
Studios For Adam Driver to play Mr
Fantastic so it looks like that's it
he's our guy most likely so the only
question now is who are going to be
playing the remaining members of the
Fantastic Four and specifically in this
video we are going to talk about the
actresses who are in the lead right now
who are in the running with Marvel
Studios to play Sue storm AKA The
Invisible Woman obviously with the news
that Adam Driver is most likely going to
be Mr Fantastic a lot of talk has been
happening about Sue storm and who
exactly has met with Marvel Studios or
who has been rumored to meet with Marvel
Studios about playing the role well in
this video we'll go over the four
actresses who are reportedly in the runs
right now for Marvel Studios it looks
like they've narrowed it down to four
but who will it be well we've got some
new reports to break down today and if
you love Marvel be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
news and so you can enter our giveaway
we'll talk more about that at the end
for a chance to win a PS5 or an Xbox
series X now today's reports are coming
from insiders and they all seem to be
saying the same thing they all seem to
have the same reports so they're most
likely accurate like I said when the Mr
fantastic news broke out everybody
started talking about Sue storm Grace
Randolph tweeted updated seems the rumor
I heard reenactress for Sue storm is
indeed legit in the running only not
decided and posted a gif of Vanessa
Kirby she also then added to her tweet
pictures of Mila Kunis Jody Comer who
has been in the running for a while and
Allison Williams now The Insider account
my time to shine hello who has a great
track record with Scoops tweeted I hear
the Mila Kunis thing is true but just
talks for now they are close to Casting
Sue probably next week now Mila Kunis
was spotted not too long ago having
lunch or dinner with the director of the
upcoming Fantastic Four movie Matt
shackman many people speculated at the
time that she was possibly meeting with
him to discuss possibly playing Sue
storm of the Fantastic Four for his
upcoming movie and it seems like that
was the case especially since they met
with each other only a few days after
Matt shackman in an interview said that
they were early in their casting process
so just based off of all of this
information about Mila Kunis and let's
call it the coincidence that she met
with the director not too long after he
announced they were casting she is
definitely one of the Front Runners
right now now the great thing about Mila
Kunis is she's done a wide range of
acting including voicing Meg from Family
Guy giving her a very comedic background
from being on That 70s Show friends with
benefits to doing things like Black Swan
and luckiest girl alive which are very
very different in tone which is good
because Sue storm needs to be serious
not all the time she can let loose
sometimes and have some fun of course
but she needs to be the person who
grounds Reed which Mila Kunis could
definitely do as an actress but let us
know what you think about option number
one for Sue storm Mila Kunis let us know
down below now another one that Grace
Randolph mentioned was Vanessa Kirby and
I absolutely love this thought I would
love for Vanessa Kirby to be Sue storm I
think she would do an incredible job she
has incredible Talent she is an Emmy
nominated actress she has work in stunts
and action because she was in the movie
Fast and Furious presents Hobbes and
Shaw she also played a role in Mission
Impossible Fallout where she played a
very Charming but serious character and
overall actually looks like Sue storm I
think so far this would be an absolutely
incredible pick it definitely makes
sense that she would be in the running
to play Sue storm now I love Mila Kunis
but I think as far as looks go Vanessa
Kirby would fit a little bit more into
the role however you could always die
Mila Kunis is hair blonde and basically
get the look for Sue storm but let me
know your thoughts about Vanessa Kirby
in the comments down below now the next
one is kind of coming out of left field
it's a name that we haven't heard to be
in the running for Sue storm and reports
or rumors or anything and that is
Allison Williams now most people know
her from her roles and Megan which was a
very recent movie and the movie get out
now very similar to Mila Kunis she has
different experiences in different
genres of film she was in those horror
movies that I just recently mentioned
plus she has done some comedic roles as
well which again is pretty necessary for
Sue storm to have that different range
and we are going to talk about chemistry
with Adam Driver because he is most
likely playing Mr Fantastic but after we
discuss the fourth option which is Jody
Comer she has been the most consistent
name mentioned for Sue storm in reports
and rumors leaks whatever you want to
say she has been out there the most and
like I mentioned in my Mr Fantastic
video she has ties with Disney and
Marvel actor soon to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe first Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool they both did the movie free
guide together and I absolutely loved
that movie and I really loved Jody
Comer's character I loved the chemistry
between her and Ryan Reynolds and free
guy was both of them working for Disney
it was made by 20th Century Fox which is
owned by Disney she clearly did a great
job with free guy and it's not that hard
for Disney to talk to her because
they've already worked with her so they
already know what it's like to work with
her and they clearly like her she also
has the look of Sue storm and she has
the range as an actress as well to play
the character and like I said since her
name has been out there a lot this makes
her one of the top contenders to play
Sue storm out of the four women that
we've talked about in this video I think
Jody Comer might have the best chance
especially if you consider that she has
worked with Disney and Adam Driver in
the past as well they were both in the
movie The Last duel now Chemistry
Between the actress who was going to be
playing Sue and the actor who is going
to be playing Mr Fantastic which is
pretty much Adam Driver is very
important especially since Kevin feige
has already confirmed that the Fantastic
Four is not gonna be a true origin story
and if some of the rumors are true read
Richards and Sue storm are already going
to be married in the movie that we see
so they'll be husband and wife which
means chemistry is extremely important
plus not to mention this is Marvel's
first family their relationship is
Iconic in the Marvel Universe in the
comics and their wedding was one of the
biggest Marvel events ever so we know
Jody Comer has chemistry already with
Adam Driver so now we have to look at
the other three women and think about
what chemistry they would have with Adam
Driver because that is exactly what
Marvel Studios is thinking right now now
all of these women would be absolutely
fantastic but they have to find that
perfect Sue storm that is Kevin feige's
goal this is his passion project his
baby he wants to be perfect I think as
far as style of acting is concerned
Vanessa Kirby would mesh really well
with Adam Driver and they also look
really great with each other you look at
them and think yeah those two could be
married but like like I mentioned any of
these actresses would be great for the
role but I do want to know what you all
think out of these four amazing women do
you have an order of who you think is
most likely to play Sue storm to least
likely let us know your thoughts down
below and according to Insider my time
to shine hello Marvel Studios will be
making an official casting decision on
who is going to play Sue storm very soon
within a couple of weeks and then of
course once that happens they'll move on
to the Human Torch the brother of Sue
storm Johnny Storm and then of course
the best friend of Reed Richards Ben
Grimm aka the thing so things are
getting really exciting in the Marvel
Universe the Fantastic Four is about to
be officially cast and hopefully Marvel
Studios reveals the official cast to us
soon but like I said let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below and if you subscribe
and leave a comment on our videos you
are entered in a giveaway for a chance
to win a PS5 and Xbox series X Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one and we announce
a winner at the end of each month don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf